اسمه الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان شكرا لك
على تحتك الفرصه هنا في فيينا
التخفيض الطوعي السعودي لنبدا به لانه
لربما الاقرب زمنيا ضمن سلسله القرارات
التي اتخذها او تم اتخاذها مساء هذا اليوم
مليون برميل يوميا لشهر يوليو طبعا ليست
اول مره تنفرد بها السعوديه في هذه
التخطيطات الطبيعيه حدثنا اكثر عن القرار
وراء هذا التخفيض تحديدا لشهر يوليو وهل
سيكون كافي لدرء الرهانات من المضاربين
على انخفاض الاسعار برايك
ما عندنا عقده مضاربين يمكن في منحاول
يدفع بهذا الكثير لكن
هي زي اللي مارسناها في عام 21
اعتقد انه كل اجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي
واعتقد انه
في ظل الظروف الراهنه كان في حاجه لاتخاذ
اجراء اضافي لكن تقديرنا هو انه في كان
بتكون صعوبات على دول لم نتواصل مع احد
لكن لانه حتى الدول قادره على التخفيض كان
لهم تخفيض في ابريل
لسه بادي نتائج المفروض نشوف تقييم
النتائجها في في منتصف يونيو
جميعا توافقنا معهم على تمديد هذه
التخفيضات التوعيه الى نهايه 24 وهذا كميه
مضافه يعني لا ننسى ان مليون وسبع مئه الف
واستمرارها لمده
سنه ونص تقريبا اي واحد يحسبها بكم حجم
الكميات البترول والله ما اعتقد يعني ما
حاول تحسبها لكن سهله الحسب لكن نعتقد انه
انيا نسوق ايضا بحاجه لتطمينات
او اجراء تحوطي يعزز الموثوقيه في انه فيه
من هو قادر بعد مشيئه الله انه يعني يتحوط
او يحوط السوق باجراءات اضافيه
تمنع
من انه يتعرض الى تذبذبات سبحان الله بعض
هذا امر غير مقبول لبعض المنتفعين ولذلك
نعتقد انه علينا واجب انه نعزز
استقرار واستدامه هذه الاستقرار الاسواق
البتوليه لان هذا معزز لاستقرار صناعه
البترول وبالتالي
وليست فقط
للمملكه لكن كافه الدول الاوبكاس وايضا
الدول المنتجه والصناعه
سمو الامير ذكرت بانه اجراء تحوطي
واحترازي بالنظر الى قرارات اليوم كان
هناك جزء كبير من هذه القرارات فيما يخص
عام 20 24 هل الصوره سلبيه برايكم الى هذه
الدرجه التي دفعتكم لاتخاذ هذه الاجراءات
المحوطيه احنا علينا واجب
نحاول نكون يعني مجددين
ما لا اريد ان اصفها بمبدعين لكن مجددين
في عمليه
اعطاء السوق صوره
مستقبليه طويله
وباليات واضحه
تعبنا من تعطي دول الحصص ما هي قادره
تنتجها
تعبنا من
ادعاءات انه يعني هذه دوله تقدر كذا وتقدر
تنشف فقلنا افضل وسيله
لمعالجه الامور هذه اللي يسمونها
بالانجليزي
انه عندك منظور او مدى واضح
تتصرف هذا المدى يتعزز عندما تكون الياتك
منضبطه باجراءات تمكن من تعزيز الموثوقيه
فيها يعني في موضوع الانتاج مراقبه
الانتاج احنا نعتمد على سبع مصادر
الان اللي سويناه جديد هو انه في بعض
الدول
[موسيقى]
رات انه ما
سوف تنتجوا في عام 24 يمكن يكون اعلى شوي
فقلنا لهم على الرحب والسعد في ثلاث جهات
دوليه معروفه
مستقله اذا اقرت انه انتاجكم ممكن يصل الى
هذه المستويات في 24 نعالج رقمكم اللي وفق
عليه اليوم
الاهم الحقيقه هو المعالجه الابديه لموضوع
الحصص
والانتاج المرجعي وهذا
وانتاج المرجع هو ان ايضا بنعتمد على
الجهه الثلاث انه من هنا من بدايه العام
24 الى منتصف 24 كل دول اوبك بلس بما في
ذلك المملكه عشان
لا يفسر هذا انه شيء من الاعتداد او شيء
من
التعالي انما قلنا لازم ابدا بنفسك هذا
قاعده تبدا بنفسك هو اعتقد هو محقق
العداله انه كل دول اوبك بلس تروح المصادر
الجهه المستقله
تعطيها كل المعلومات المطلوبه بحيث انها
تتاكد انه والله الارقامها فيما سوف تنتجه
خمسه 25
هو فنيا سليم وصحيح وممكن ان تصادق عليه
هذا يعفينا من الجدليه الداخليه في في كل
مناشط كل يعني
اجهزه المنظمه او اللجان المنظمه لانه
بتاخذ الطابع
الغير يعني بقضيه المفاوضات اكثر من انها
تقييم فني يراعي
معايير فنيه واضحه سمو الامير هل تعتقد
بانه هذه الاليه والاعتماد على
المراقبين المستقلين
ستنظف الدفاتر من البراميل الورقيه غير
الحقيقيه هذا الاصل هذا الاصل
وليس هناك وسيله متاحه الان
الا الاعتماد على جهاد مستقله
مشهود بالموثوقيه
وهذا الادعاء لانه لا ندخل انفسنا في انه
يتحول موضوع الى انا عشت لفترات السابقه
في الثمانينات والتسعينات وكانت في نهايه
المطاف الحصص وماسه وينتج هو عمليه تفوضيه
اكثر من انها عمليه تستند على
الجوانب الفنيه دقيقه ولا موضوعيه سؤال
الاخير سمو الامير تقييمكم لمستويات
الانتاج الروسي والتزامهم خاصه بالحديث
بانه يعني
الامدادات الروسيه وصادراتها الى الصين
الى الاسواق العالميه قد تكون منفصله
حقيقه على ارض الواقع من مستويات الانتاج
يعني بغض النظر عن مستويات الانتاج
الامدادات الروسيه ما زالت قويه بالرغم من
العقوبات لهذا كله كلام الناس انت
تتابع يمكن اكثر مني
ما ينشروا كذا يعني خلينا
نركز على الجانب الموضوعي اكثر من الجانب
الغير موضع الجانب الموضوعي انه احنا الى
الان لا نعرف كم انتجت روسيا في مايو لانه
المصادر السبع لم تنشر معلوماتها الا
تقريبا بنص يونيو
كان لنا نقاش مع
روسيا والجانب الروسي في انه عليكم
مسؤوليه في انكم تكون واضحين تكون
وشفافين في اعطاء المعلومات ثم اخذوا من
فتره قرار بعدم نشر معلومات اعتقد انه
الان يعرفون انه عدم نشر المعلومات
ادى الى ظهور هذه الظاهره الجديده من
التشكيك في معلومات ارقامهم وكذا انما
الحقيقه الان وقدام الملا يعني في المؤتمر
الصحفي ذكرت لاربع جهات من الجهات اللي من
السبع الجهات اللي نعتمد عليها في عمليه
تقييم الارقام الشهريه انه تواصلوا معاهم
اعطوهم معلومات اضافيه ذكرهم بعض الجوانب
اللي يعتقدون كان فيها خلل او خطا
والاضافه الى ذلك
التزموا انه يتواصلوا معهم شهريا للتثبت
فعشان كذا بتلقى في الاتفاق حطينا انه
انتاج فبراير روسيا هو جالس يعاد النظر في
من اربع من الجهات
السبع في ثلاث جهات لظروف الحظر وكذا هي
غير قادر على التواصل مع الجانب الروسي
لكن قلنا اذا كان فيه تعديل لشهر فبراير
من خلال اخذ معدل مره اخرى ارقام الجهه
السبع بافتراض انه اي من الاربع جهات رحت
تعدل شيء
بيؤخذ فيه وهذا فيه عداله
للجميع وايضا بس احنا في ممارستنا هذه مع
روسيا عززنا مفهوم الشفافيه
فيما يتعلق بانتاجه شكرا جزيلا لك اسمه
الامير وعلى اتاحتكم لنا هذه الفرصه هنا
رامز والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات